hello again everyone I'm Steve pity for
those whom I haven't met faculty and
history in American Studies and
ethnicity race and migration and
director of the RIT M Center it's a real
honor and a privilege to introduce
today's keynote speaker
Howard Winant professor of sociology at
the University of California Santa
Barbara where he is also affiliated with
the Black Studies Chicano Chicano
Studies and asian-american Studies
department whinin has been enormous ly
influential as I'm sure all of you know
in those fields and many others as a
wide ranging thinker and as a generous
and brilliant writer advisor and
colleague he founded and directed the
University of California center for new
racial studies his research and writing
has focused on racial theory and social
theory and on comparative historical
sociology political sociology and
cultural sociology of race both in the
United States and globally
Howard Winans the author of a number of
important books including the new
politics of race globalism difference
justice the world is a ghetto race and
democracy since World War two racial
conditions politics Theory comparisons
racial formations in the United States
from the 1960s to the 1990s co-authored
with Michael Oh me and stalemate
political economic origins of
supply-side policy we are thrilled we
are grateful that Howard Winant is here
today to deliver this keynote address he
will speak for a while and then has
agreed to take questions from and
comments from the audience in advance of
lunch please join me in welcoming Howard
wine
[Applause]
she okay
raise your hand if you can hear me okay
great thanks
well thanks first of all to organizers
of this conference
Steve pity and Mori Samuel it's a it's a
pleasure to be here let me just say that
I we have a little personal introduction
that I am the son of Holocaust survivors
of refugees from the Nazis born in New
York City you know as a longtime
anti-racist activists and scholar I have
to say that I owe my work oh my work on
race and racism and in some ways my very
existence I've always felt it that's
fascism and and this conference ago it
does not have the word fascism in the
title it definitely has a word fascism
in it subtext my title working for the
clampdown comes from the clash and I'll
be showing of Roe clip from the clash in
a minute it's a big tough talk for me to
write I have to say also I I was daunted
by the rapidly moving event I started to
write before show still happened and
before we came to learn that the Pope
had a Jewish psychoanalyst in Buenos
Aires in the 1970s
1980s I guess it's many there's a
tremendous number of topics framings one
can go through this a national global
natural versus global framings
historical versus contemporary stuff and
i think the demands on a keynote speaker
is basically to try to frame the
conference in a certain way to introduce
or at least point to some issues that he
or she considers key and hopefully
contribute so I can make this computer
do its thing continue to further
discussion this is gonna happen later on
and maybe in the question period too
I'm going to emphasize the US and the
present but not entirely I want to look
outside US as well US borders and I also
want to look back in time a bit
so um hmm sounds switch slides sorry
just trying to make it it's not my
computer okay so my talk would be
focused on these the three themes that
are in our title racism anti-semitism
in America right when we deal with these
themes but I think the first thing we
have to remember is their human
consequences the infinite suffering that
each one of these seemingly cold or
academic or detached notions actually
contains you know I can't go into detail
about that suffering here but you know
you all know about the take the camps
extermination camps the slave ships the
lynchings the daily despair and misery
the horror and the terror that are
passed within a term like racism or
anti-semitism or really the freight of
the radical right in certain ways and
you also know I think about the
incredible the miraculously even well
okay miraculous triumphs and victories
of the victims of these immensely
oppressive ideologies of systems of
thought and practice what has been
achieved by African victims of the
African slave trade a the Atlantic slave
trade I guess I'm particularly talking
about but there's also of course a
trance of our African slave trade and an
Indian Ocean African slave trade I won't
get into that too much today you know
about what Jews have achieved beyond our
survival you know about what immigrants
and refugees have accomplished their
triumphs their political gains with
political victories so it's not just a
history of suffering it's also a trance
music transcendent element that I want
to try and talk about so when we talk
about the links we'll explore the links
we see not only that these are murderous
authoritarian ideologies but also that
are based in authoritarian populism
authoritarian regimes of different sorts
but each uses scapegoating generally a
vulnerable minority populations and
everything I say there are some
exceptions every you have to apologize
in advance for the generality of what
I'm talking about because to cover the
ground that I'm hoping to cover up I
have to go wider and not so deep I mean
we can't think of racist ideologies that
are not racist practices racist regimes
for example that are not involved in
oppressing my minorities but majority is
a South African case the most obvious
example we can come up with exceptions
though right I hope my generalities in
general hold up in terms of accuracy
accuracy okay eat and eat talk about the
connections between these three terms
racism anti-semitism and the radical
right um
each seeks to mobilize a mass base
against that vulnerable minority or
minorities okay
so what's new the clash already said to
all this stuff I said in the first verse
of working through the Clint I take a
moment and read the lyrics
I won't read them to you sometimes I do
have to read the screen but I feel it's
a little bit offensive to read the
screen and powerpoints at least every
time all right I'm going to play a few
less than a minute of working for the
clamp down by the clash so we have to
turn the volume up I think let's see if
it happens here Hayes wants to UM no no
no this thing we've all done doesn't
need to be a thing there's a smart way
to stay fresh eggs with fresh IQ it that
really messes with you okay here we go
about a minute of this with the beauty
of these guys toast from her the other
day
oh wait you don't have video
wait we have it we have a good cheer I'm
seeing the video on my screen but you're
not seeing the video this is a
tremendous threat in my style
okay switch do what you need to do man
against my time
so this is a hyperlink just right on it
yeah what on
right this way no I'm getting a great
view of look here okay
it's gonna happen they're so deep for
your max all the tanks to the airport as
if I'm wrong all the other David
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay the lyrics again and by the way I
have to switch presentation forms here
but take a moment to read the lyrics
sorry for technical glitches okay so now
I'm gonna proceed to talk about our
three terms racism anti-semitism and the
radical right I'm taking liberty of
defining racism myself because I think
there's actually a lot of confusion and
a lot of debate obviously we may have
differences in the room about what they
mean by racism that confusion is not
only on the racist right or on the
political right not only in the US
Supreme Court which seems to think that
racism is a problem mainly experienced
by whites but it's also on the left and
this is this is another thing we can
discuss if you want later I've been
involved in some debates about this
formula racism equals prejudice plus
power trying to counter that in my view
simplistic and highly problematic
definition so I'm offering a more
complicated three-part definition which
which is dependent on the whole a tional
formation concept the idea that race is
a itself a social construct people are
very familiar with this now I think and
so what we're talking about is these
three elements signifying practice on
the one hand and
something discursive a set of social
actions that's not only discursive Oh
surely not apart from it and third a
social structural dimension that is
built into the experience over
historical time of the experience of
these significations and these actions
being repeated being embedded being
reiterated over time reiteration is it
is another concept I want to get back to
you
so it seems eternal we have a tendency
to figure forget that we live in history
you see we tend to take the present as
given and I'm relatively unmuted but in
fact race racism like race itself is
flexible it's unstable it's
contradictory it changes and develops it
adapts to anti-racist resistance and it
also suffers setbacks and we do have to
connect racism with fascism in North
America that connection goes back to
settler colonialism and anti and
Atlantic slavery we have our own brands
of genocide ethnic cleansing ghettos
persecution of immigrants which
correspond to but do not overlap with
other brands
around the world concepts that you may
hear later here about later from Tim
Schneider aliens realm of genocide out
this way o ethnic cleansing connects you
u.s. frameworks there pillars of settler
colonialism not only in the u.s.
actually but across the Americas by the
way Hitler refers to the genocide of the
Indians and also to the Armenian
Genocide in mine Kampf
and I don't know if James Whitman is
possibly in the room here law professor
at Yale has already come up in the
earlier panel about how much the Nazis
learned from American racism then
there's a KKK order not to talk too
extensively about that days there's
linked Lindbergh's America first
committee America first reiteration
their various neo-nazis and of course
more many more kinds that could be
mentioned in the United States they all
go back to the country's origins as a
sex slave aqua see see the Civil War and
the defeat of reconstruction after
twelve years of the first reconstruction
they go back to nativism nativism
in the u.s. context means
anti-immigration anti-immigrant biology
the alien ax was 1719 to know-nothing
party officially called the American
native party of the
the of the late antebellum period for
example the gun units in America in the
United States go back to the Second
Amendment of the Constitution which was
specifically drafted to enable
slaveholders to confront and in a
violent way slave insurrection they also
go back to the paddy rollers you see
slave patrols you know the cover of the
book like Sally Hatton the pattyroller
was a black turn for patrollers an
organized system of armed white what we
would now call working-class young men
low-income white patrolling of the
antebellum South arm to catch Runaways
and discipline slaves and then forced
pass laws so these are our history this
is our history I'm gonna leap ahead I've
for reasons of time I cut out of Jimmy's
number one man it's made several slides
whoa once why is Versailles etc to World
War two I'm like leaping ahead to World
War two and after World War two
I've argued the u.s. racial regime
officially changed sides well well it's
not only the US facial aging the world
resolution actually officially changed
sighs can we talk about a world racial
regime that might be something to
discuss on a world level white supremacy
was largely European white supremacy was
largely about before World War two
obviously not in every case after during
and after World War two it
to be disavowed this is an enormous
chef's but I've called a worldwide
racial break a rupture me this upheaval
was over determined multiply determined
by numerous factors I don't want to get
into them all now but the war itself was
generally seen generally depicted at
least the Atlantic war as an anti-racist
war the Pacific War not so much the Cold
War was a racial confrontation in many
many ways that the rise of anti-imperial
movements around the world and to
colonial movements or reraised really
reiteration after world war ii was
obviously a racial event or the complex
racial situation but that everything i
need to talk too much more about that
but the challenge to empire that arose
during war doing really join but also
after war to harness roots in the war
itself the fact that people all over the
world not just in the United States or
in Europe but all over the world were
armed to fight colonial occupation on
the part of the Japanese are on the part
of the Germans and then the old
colonizers come back and say hey
surrender your guns give up your your
autonomy not quite so the Vietnam War or
the Algerian war or conflicts all over
the world this was just one of the other
factors that led to the anti-racist
upsurge
war would show trying to change toys
again so now the racial trajectory on a
world scale shifting again there's a
reaction to post-world War two
anti racism to feminism to immigration a
movements we call identity politics
which was formed in many ways by anti
racism had now come under a new type of
fire I think it's really important as we
despair as I must submit in the first
panel
I was despairing as we despair about the
rise of the right as we despair about
total fascism New Testament actually I
want to drop those prefixes and just
talk about fascism if you're a
neo-fascist
you're a fascist as we despair about
that we should recognize that there's
been a tremendous freakout on the right
this is really true in the United States
particularly with our gay in this moment
as the fear of a majority minority
society has dawned on the right people
may remember the autopsy report that
went it was very powerful in the
Republican Party after the 2012 defeat
Romney by Obama the client all right the
argument being hey the demographics of
the United States is such that if we do
not appeal to the voters of color we're
going to lose some serious elections the
kind of nativism anti-immigrant politics
that we've seen the rise of
the right in general I'm arguing on a
world scale again has a lot to do with
the gains that were made the rise of
more democratic more racially inclusive
politics after World War two not just in
the u.s. although the US may be
particularly paradigmatic about this so
that you know you can see at the at the
top of the slide a perceived demographic
threat I'm talking about roughly 25
years from now the US will no longer be
a majority white country America has not
a white man's country the threat of that
on the right is very significant the
gains we have made needs to be need to
be remembered as we confront the crisis
situation that we're in today
but the old themes definitely remain as
well they're repeated in new ways
reiteration is something that absolutely
strikes me always strikes me so
intensely as I try as I tried to study
Rachel for racial formation and racial
politics the rising tide of color loaf
of Stoddard on the left by the way it
was American cannot see and there's
another one of these people who received
a medal from I think Goering
that was bestseller in the 1920
following him closely on the Madison
branch the passing of the Great Race
1916 these were the lean in books of
their time the I mean I would say the
Jack Jackie Collins books of their time
but close to that if threat of the
threat of racial justice the threat of
racial inclusion the threat of abolition
sorry
and also the adaptation over time of
what Natalia Molina calls racial scripts
from one context to another Natalia is
talking about within the US but I think
there's a great global dimension
comparative dimension of that's good by
the way thanks to Danny hoaxing is here
who reminded me of of Elena's analysis
racism so on racism it hurts white
people too
that is not a general perception but it
is the case this is extremely visible in
all sorts of situations as
republican-led states refused to expand
Medicaid
after the Obamacare the mixed Obamacare
decision from the Roberts Court millions
of whites are denied access to health
insurance because we don't want get
those black people health care many many
other examples a weekend we can cite the
ways in which white supremacy and racism
denies benefits the benefits of the
welfare state of social democracy to
whites as
well as non wise the ways in which it
depresses wages for whites for everybody
including wise freaked out
white people insecure white males
fearful authoritarian personalities our
being interpolated are being hailed
being called out called to buy new
reiterated old forms of racism what's
the difference between I want my country
back and make America great again
certainly the groundwork for Trump's
victory which was created by corrupt
election practices I would say more than
anything else but also created by real
right-wing populist forces is the racism
built into the popular forces by the way
I use face authoritarian personality
okay the Adorno legacy the Frankfurt
School legacy the legacy of kiss-up
takedown is so central particularly in
American culture moving now to
anti-semitism I mentioned that on the a
child of Jewish refugees but most people
most Jews seeking to enter the United
States in the 1930s observe wars
declaration by the US and 1941 were
denied entry they resistance to Jewish
immigration in the 1930s was not so
different from the resistance to Muslim
today this reason by the way the
question an immigrant versus refugee
which is another thing we could debate
we could discuss this is sociological
distinction between those two I think
this highly sup suspects also raises a
question of Orientalism are Jews
Occidental or oriental we used to be
oriental we only got to be Occidental a
few decades ago again huge hunting is
moving to anti-semitism use continuities
between the anti that anti-semitism of
the past and that of the present but
also big shifts in recent years
did you is still the other still not
truly American or false ed or Hungarian
or whom at whatever country Jews are
just in veterans and veteran Lee
International cosmopolitan scientists
and plays a role in this but it's not
the source of it it's the Apollonian
character of Jews the fact that we are
not autochthonous that we don't have a
land of our own this is something we can
debate that generates this cosmopolitan
other nests anathema that we face see
the Miller just a few weeks ago raised
use that term cosmopolitan and dissing
the Emma Lazarus poem on the Statue of
Liberty I'm sure most of you picked up
on that the Jewish tell the fans here
they user user and simultaneously the
Communists the Jews
the Jews control Wall Street in
Hollywood don't you know I can never
offer by the way an adequate treatment
of anti-semitism here so many
connections I'm neglecting I will make
some more in a minute
especially those between anti-semitism
and racism big literature's on that
today's ships anti-semitism in my view
and not just my view obviously come from
conflicts over Israel Palestine
Christian Zionism we already had in
erudite discussion it's a really big
like right-wing thing now it's built in
my view on Islamophobia and sometimes on
them under the revelations and the
rapture and so on it's also built on the
mammoth shifts of Israel as a nation
there's political shift of Israel as a
nation to the right wing so you can be
both anti-semitic and Zionists at the
same time
dr. Hummel says well maybe then it's not
so anti-semitic the Christian Right is
it used to be I question that is done a
lot more research than I have on this
topic but when you look at the base of
the Christian Right I think you will
find the continuity of anti-semitism
they're straight-up Zionism if
straight-up Zionism is also is generally
anti-semitic I'm sorry Islamophobia by
the same token straight-up Islamism is
generally as a Semitic I don't think it
really big doubts about these
things maybe you want to argue and
question that although most
anti-semitism is profoundly right-wing
historically and still today in the
present
there's also left-wing anti-semitism my
general view is that it is possible to
be anti Zionist without being
anti-semitic this is a big struggle
we're end in this country this is a big
struggle we're in in the world it has to
do with the efforts of the Israeli
government to make Zionism with Judaism
as inextricably as possible that's
problematic baby there are plenty of
Jews or not Zionists
it is however quite possible to be both
anti Zionist and anti-semitic so this is
a tough question I think it was half
question for people on the left but
anyway for the last 40 years essentially
African Camp David the Israeli
leadership has been in bed with the US
Christian right and other white
nationalists and neo-fascists I use the
term again fascists around the world
Robin was probably the only exception in
terms of the top is Israeli leadership
and he was late and he was killed he was
late to come to that position but he did
come to it and then it cost him his life
Israel has always been Islamophobic
that is to say racist although another
left-wing current has existed before
1948 and to some extent after 1948 that
was not
even a leveling zionist can't existed
before 1948 and after 1948 to some
extent that was not Islamophobic and I
would recommend Joel bindings work on
this on labor movements in Israel so it
is not surprising to see these alliances
at work today to see Netanyahu embracing
or bond or bond who plays miklós horthy
a Nazi regent of Hungary and who comes
directly out of that tradition to see
Narendra Modi who was deeply involved in
Dennis Idol violence in Gujarat making
love metaphorically with Netanyahu of
course there's also the Alliance now
quite open between the Israeli
leadership and the Saudis so maybe this
characterization of Israel and Zionism
as Islamophobic should be qualified in
some respects maybe it's a more
anti-shia
than anti swimming Islamophobia but
that's a new thing that hasn't been
always been around any honest observer
from my view will testify that
internally Israel is extremely racist
it's racist not only towards Arabs it's
racist towards me jockeys it's racist
choice beta is neo Jews from Ethiopia
it's racist towards its own dark peoples
and they occupied territories
filled with Americans although many of
them of the Connie type are is a is an
extremely racist place I mean I was in
is your last time well I'm not so as I
was in Asia but a fairly recent time
that I was in Israel I saw on the walls
of the old city in Jerusalem painted in
English a slogan Arabs rouse and over
reference to Nazism now I want to show
you another another rock video this
one's four minutes I'm gonna have to
change my display type again so give me
a second
my beloved Leonard Cohen I'm not sure if
it's working this scene I loved his
cover for this album 1992 album the
future with its Buell art it's birds
singing and it's undone chain or maybe
handcuffs here we go
turn it out there oh not happening once
more this is so breaking my heart I
can't do this right let's see here I'm
sorry rock videos optimistic wrap hang
in with me
sure cramps my rhythm style I said
that's link yeah there we go
No
[Music]
there's no
[Music]
soon
that's an order
[Music]
it's left
in Huckle
if
bang
whoa give it style benefit all of see
[Music]
1992
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
the soul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the bath
I've seen damnations rounds and fall of
her
but their mom
love's the only engine of survival
the cars like
[Music]
you can
[Music]
there's a
[Music]
where
[Music]
West
[Music]
son
[Music]
you see you
my shoes white said
the features
[Music]
mousy little Poli some common ground
trying to sound Charlotte lands
[Music]
Gold is fire
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
of the
[Music]
[Applause]
witnesses
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm back to my format here again
that's my slide that's how okay yeah I'm
going on wait too long I'm really sorry
okay looking at the right the radical
right now the third term in our title I
think it's important to see the right
the radical right in terms of race class
gender intersectionality this is a term
I'm sure everybody knows by now at Yale
and everywhere else it's not only an
aggregate of race and class and gender
we need to look at all three of them we
need to see how they combine its
attempts at synthesis as Ken Cranshaw
has argued it involves quote reciprocal
II constructed phenomenon which sounds
kind of like dialectics to me this means
that we have to look not only at the way
that race and class and gender shape
each other in particular experiences
individual and collective but that we
also have to look at intersectionality
or these this synthesis synthesize
notion of race class and gender in
historical context and national and
historical context and that way I think
it's important to recognize the common
origins of Islamophobia and
anti-semitism while Islam is not as old
as Judaism the histories of
anti-semitism an anti Islam ISM have a
lot in common they have a common
starting point in world history which is
in my view their ethnic Keith Dunn
of the Iberian Peninsula the wreckin
Kisa
was a historical event that took place
over 600 or so years depending on how
you want to count and it sent
essentially involved the Inquisition the
Inquisition as a bureau of state terror
and widespread persecution torture and
repression okay so in my slide when we
think about race the race component of
intersectionality that's what I want to
do now race gender and class and
intersectionality as the core elements
of the radical right in the u.s. settler
colonialism in Atlantic slavery or
central to race in the United States and
also native is an anti-immigration ism
but but an empire peculiar thing about
us the u.s. is that it is it's got this
foundational contradiction of being the
first large-scale anti-imperial anti
colonial nation while at the same time
being built in a very fundamental way on
Empire and colonialism itself from the
very beginning as a settler colonial
civilization okay indeed so that's the
u.s. in the u.s. in eastern I'm sorry in
Eastern and yeah not in Europe you have
to add anti Islamism and anti-semitism
to the mix that's already been been
mentioned the Turkish invasions and so
on large scale anti-semitism goes way
back in Eastern Europe and then we have
to go beyond North America and Europe to
think about Hindutva as a racist
religious philosophy in India to think
about turkey Turkey and him army
genocide just to pick one thing to think
about the Balkans when we also this came
to power in the Balkans
and Serbia this has been his main effort
his main source of power was
demonization of Muslims and in Latin
America
Pinochet vue de la ville say a little
bit more about them in a moment
you have to think about the legacy of
the Crusades Crusades overlap with the
reckon Keith Dunn so it's helmet well we
need to go back they need to go back to
World War two we need to go back to
Versailles we need to go back to peace
of westphalia
we need to go back even further this is
something that we don't often we on the
Left who challenge one a challenge
anti-semitism and Islamophobia do not
often think about the continuity with
the Reconquista because it was not just
anti-jewish
it was also anti-muslim the Crusades
were not only anti-muslim they were also
anti-jewish
Islamophobes are fascists they invoke
the Counter Reformation as Franco dead
as Pinochet did as Videla did and also
other Latin American dictators and also
Steve Bannon we're gonna have a talk on
that and that I think is going to take
us a lot cheaper than I am taking us I
have found six places in Spain and not
in America mainly cities that are named
Matamoros don't think about that name
does that mean killed Muslims dead
Muslims in this it's uh you can see the
Crusaders cross okay I talked about on
the radical right gender I think we have
to again again looking at
intersectionality we have to look at the
radical right and gender Michael Kimmel
sociologists brothers sociologist
brother Zhu it forms the present date
bewilderment and resentment of white men
and boys both in the US and around the
world confronting economic uncertainty
racial and gender equality and even
educational setbacks by the way numerous
universities in the United States are
practicing affirmative action for men as
women outstrip men and academic
qualifications and some IVs are doing
that as well I can't say that Yale is I
don't know in the Muslim world as well
there is a tremendous crisis of
masculinity but this crisis is worldwide
I give you a lot Amir Putin's
masculinity issues white right wing
movements fascist movements on men's
movements not entirely obviously but in
significant ways
Mahima pen pal Quebec Petri many other
fascists
women leaders are the exception not the
rule
see Catherine Kathleen please work on
women in the clan for a US version of
that analysis now by the way this but
this discussion of gender and the
radical right does not do justice to
anything it doesn't do justice to
sexuality dimension to homophobia
transphobia as well as homo nationalism
just be a part work all these things
need to be taken into account
maybe the central question still is
though watching you
let us turn class radical light in class
the capitalist economy is in a prolonged
crisis
I can't accumulate wealth by traditional
means it's on state-sponsored life
support I read in the business section
in the New York Times that Mario Draghi
is contemplating reducing quantitative
easing in other words inflationary
button money printing and the EU and
that of course it's also true that this
is that the Federal Reserve Board it is
contemplating doing that as well and
being pressured by certain forces to do
that but there are no significant
profits to be made any longer in the
production of traditional commodities
the big profits are made through finance
and Finance is subsidized directly by
this cast of characters on the bottom of
your screen Keynes family famously spoke
of the gradual euthanasia of the rent EA
and he envisioned with that statement
and other work a transition to social
democracy well the absolute opposite of
that has happened what does this mean
for politics politics I guess that you
Jeff Ely paper touched on this point you
um politics in u.s. politics in Europe
positives around the world are
characterized by hostility on both the
left and the right to finance capital
in the crisis workers but workers
globally the u.s. middle class poor
people everywhere I'm being screwed a
headline on all dot all right calm reads
regular white kids won't be going to
college anymore the labor crisis the
jobless future the sense of being left
behind is a major source of Husein Timon
I mean it sounds so much better than
French resentment the resentment that is
fueling from that is fueling breaths
brexit and lapel and everywhere else in
the world this is very intersectional
it's not just class obviously its class
but it's also race and gender because
what jobs we mean I chose jobs more
likely occupationally sex typed as women
jobs they're low wage jobs competing so
you're competing with immigrants and
people of color we previously you were
defended from that so again this is a
big reiteration of 19th century white
working-class racism in the US and
Beyond nativism in the US and Beyond
hostility to abolition hostility to
immigration in the US and Beyond and
then and then there are the white-collar
knowledge industry jobs for which low
skills young white men cannot compete by
the way I say Germany is something of an
exception to this
talk about you mean you know but I can
if you wanted to do that well it's a
Jetson the capitalist class doesn't
necessarily support Trump yes the
right-wing to has its hostility to Wall
Street so what and and not all the
countless class not all white wall she
considers itself
right-wing so [ __ ] allies now the head
of work CC other CEOs who abandoned Tom
Elon Musk who resist Union the Joint
Chiefs of Staff the CIA the FBI is that
who were relying on do we suddenly agree
with people who have very significant
anti-democratic inclinations Steve ban
calls a bob cut nur of the American
Prospect and wraps him about inequality
what do we do with that I won't talk
about season the notion I know he's been
an issue on his campus I'm getting to
the end very quickly I went on too long
um this is history history about present
crisis is long-standing its world making
nationalism eugenics scientific racism
hostility immigration really
reinvigorated religious conflicts
institutional sexism are some of the
main currents at work in the present
fascism very come
and historically as long as I mean very
have to be looked at very comparatively
and historically in contrast to Hitler's
extermination extermination ISM
Mussolini Franco and other fascists were
less focused on Jews although they were
hardly free of the anti-semitism
themselves
I recommend Zell Stern hell's book the
birth of modern fascist ideology somehow
deals with fascism as a coherent
ideological movement the only European
alternative it's a liberalism and commie
with communism with rich from which it
borrowed extensively it's also really
important to recognize that Latin
fascism's I played a major role in
shaping the Americas I may already
mentioned Franco his influence on Brazil
also saw as our influence on Brazil on
Argentina on Chile and transforming
traditional what was called Coronel
dismal into how do you smoke it's very
very significant in terms of the the
right wing of surgeries that we've seen
in Latin America and maybe are seeing
again in Latin America by the way in
terms of Brazil and half at its own
fascist movement called integral DS mode
which was more or less related to Italy
I'm not integral yzma had a particular
peel to black Brazilians afro-brazilians
which is an interesting problem we can
deal with it at another time I'll just
slide over this this slide very quickly
it's not
so clear to me that Europe is
consolidating to the right it is to some
extent is to be sure as Mark Rome's
sunny drop in popularity precipitous
drop indicates Corbin seems to be
hanging in there we don't know about the
u.s. election electoral pattern at all
at this point so to conclude we're in a
moment of crisis capitalist crisis
political crisis socio-cultural prices
we can't easily fall into despair we
should remember though that there are
important counter traditions of which we
are apart the leading countered
tradition in the United States is the
Dubois e what Dubois described as
abolition democracy and the voices view
the American Revolution was the first as
it was a partial and income the original
American Revolution was a parcel and
incomplete anti-imperial revolution
dominated by white elites obviously
right property to these male the civil
war and black week reconstruction
aborted as it was were the second phase
of the American Revolution based upon it
and then and there you get the first
reconstruction based upon the expansion
of the rights and possibilities that
emancipation offered ie what he called
expanded democracy and full citizenship
the second reconstruction took place in
in our own time of some of our own times
the elders among us
in the 1960s meet John Lewis's address
this is the same occasion the same day
that dr. King gave his I have a dream
speech we're involved in a serious
social revolution this is the threat
that the current right experiences in
the United States can we imagine a third
reconstruction not only in the US but an
equivalent a parallel process going on
around the world
Reverend barbers movement which used to
be called what the moral Monday movement
has now called forward together
represents one vision this is the
nonviolent vision and there are many
nonviolent anti-racist movements all
around the world it's not just a u.s.
thing as a political movement as a
democratic movement we need non-violence
not just tactically but as a political
principle at the same time we have this
antifoam an anti-fascist movement which
represents another vision
equally important wounded in time
unnecessary dimension of resistance of
fascism in US history there's a long a
long tradition of armed self-defense
against white violence the othe african
black brotherhood founded by civil
briggs this guy here on the right in
1919 later became part of the commons
party well okay there's a lot of other
things to the Deacons itself to fit for
self-defense Robert F was and the 90
fifteen North Carolina the Black Panther
Party today of many people around the
world a resisting fascism resisting
fascist violence and not in a
non-violent way their force to violent
means to resist violent means the Golden
Dawn in Greece fascists and humans
European countries the Klan and its
allies cannot be fought only with
non-violence this is true everywhere
this is an ongoing tension that we face
since there is tremendous potential for
provocation for provocateurs in the
anti-fat movement and yet at the same
time we need to defend ourselves while
maintaining our continuing commitment to
non-violence please forgive me for going
on so long thank you very much
[Music]